hi my name is Christian I'm a graduate
student at ple through high school I'm
Carol Chen I could return to high school
I'm 15 hi i'm marcelo neil and i'm grade
12 at university of toronto schools and
we'll be presenting recap intelligent
note-taking so recap is an intelligent
note taking out that we developed at the
m hax 9 hackathon back in march
know what a hackathon is no one ok how
do you guys have been to a hackathon
okay so hackathon is basically a
programming competition where students
from around the world gather at a
usually a university there are general
admission ones to build a project so
what we are gonna demo today was built
in a frenzy of 36 hours of no showers
little sleep in a lot of caffeine
alright so yeah like you said hackathons
also sometimes come with a theme and so
the theme for the hack found that we
participated in em hacks 9 was to create
something that contained or that pertain
to the topic epi driven design and so
here's our app yeah so the problem that
we came up with is we're pretty bad at
taking notes it's not that we're bad at
writing or anything it's just it's
really hard to find a balance between
like notes to have a lot of information
in a very detail-oriented and notice
that you can write quickly and have like
shorthand notes so personally when it
comes to a studying for an exam I have
notes from like four or five months ago
that seem like they don't make any sense
to me anymore they are completely
incoherent out of context so and a lot
of the time I have to like Google the
terms and make sense of it
so I so this was a problem that we tried
to address at this hack saw it was a
simple online solution it was a
full-featured text editor where you can
take notes
we built it off firebase in react Jes so
that included it will go on the
dedication autosave and we have they
have these other two bullet points
intelligent recording and playback and
WolframAlpha integration which you will
be seeing in our demo we can see here
there are three of us and four people in
that photo that a fourth person suck
into the from the left is Kevin pay and
fortunately he cannot be here with us
today because he's suffering through
midterms which is not that bad cause he
has her app
but I'm okay so generally were you
overview of the hackathon so we was like
it was pretty interesting
it was uh so one thing about hackathons
is hackathons allow you to basically
surround yourself with a lot of
programmers who are really interested in
same fields as you are in write a soft
development and and so this allows for a
great atmosphere for you to actually
learn new frameworks or tools or
languages and so one of the main
language that we learned at the
hackathon was it was a framework was
react and before we went in there we
knew next to nothing about react but at
the end of the weekend we came out with
a pretty nice app yeah so we actually
ended up placing second at the hackathon
as well as winning the Wolfram price so
and additionally if you've never been to
a hackathon before or involved yourself
in a hackathon I highly suggest it even
like a general admission hackathon
because you learn a lot of cool stuff
and it's really fun
Oh a quick introduction here there's
some hackathons that are global I know
there's one the klamath on and there's
also a fish hackathon coming up and so
yeah those are generally mission
accomplished okay so this is our demo
it's currently live recap but one that
that mean case you guys didn't catch
that I'm gonna throw up in your document
and okay I'm gonna say what is the is
the professor saying I'd much rather be
asleep so and in this now I'm gonna go
back I'm gonna hit that play button and
hopefully it is playing so that way I
play by work so if I were to start
hitting here and say hi this is a new
part of text I am typing
so those are the difference between our
app and kind of just standalone
recording as the Paulin standalone
recording is that even if you had the
recording and your notes there's no way
of matching what you wrote with what was
being said when you wrote it so we kind
of solved that problem
and it also does a thing where it saves
it's a separate audio file if you type
in a new location so if you have like a
really bad lecturer which I'm surround
between topics no problem other feature
is that you can actually graph equations
and this is our Wolfram Alpha
implementation I'm not you see this
asleep this you see this keyboard I
don't welcome notice how to understand
that um I don't know how to click okay
sorry is it okay I'm gonna go I'm x
squared had you
so this is a difficult to select okay so
basically can do anything you want you
calculate large factorials if you wish
and Sirois dis works is we're actually
integrating the app with the Wolfram
Alpha API and so you just have to
highlight what section of texts you may
want clarification on and it'll give you
more context on information and so in
conjunction in conjunction with the
playback and the quick and easy to
search tools of our editor students who
are taking notes in class can easily
gain context on what the professor is
saying and we believe that this will
help take how he'll take their notes its
calculate a large factorial if I can use
this touchpad yeah so it's like this one
of the things of Wolfram Alpha
okay anyway okay let's go back to
presentation
no that's fine uh you can always go onto
the website yourself if you want yeah oh
one laptop so we encounter a lot of
problems as most software projects do so
one of the issues we had is we wanted to
implement speech-to-text obviously if
you're recording a bunch of data it'd be
great to analyze that maybe get a
transcript unfortunately a lot of the
speech-to-text
api sorry either really expensive or
really bad actually especially since the
keyboard adds a lot of noise and the
laptop microphones aren't very effective
additionally when we develop this app
the node package manager didn't have a
lock file so when we tried to test our
app like a few months after the
hackathon all of the dependencies didn't
work together anymore
so that was unfortunate and our
difficulty was when we're trying to
aligned recordings with the sections of
notes that you guys types it was really
hard to actually maintain that range of
characters inside our map in the of the
text editor because you could actually
insert text in the middle of a recording
and that would be a separate recording
so yeah it was difficult story actually
we found that being speech-to-text was
immoral liable than google's which we
found also disappointing a lot of other
features we can add to kind of perfect
this note-taking experience the obvious
one here is document sharing as you
already kind of do that whether you're
passing physical paper notes to a friend
or your fish sharing on Google Docs we
because we're on firebase and are like
every all the data stored real-time so
every character you type is always saved
and should you be typing another tab it
will update in any other open tabs so
document sharing should be relatively
easy to implement the other thing we
really want is formula rendering because
there's this terrible situation we're in
right now where you can't do math
digitally because simply because like
writing large fractions can be difficult
yes latex exists but I mean who uses
that to practice math right so if you
can get a built in calculator going and
a proper or Wolfram like more
mathematical integration can get a
really nice formula rendering system the
other problem is that well it's because
we can't fix the problem of laptop makes
being crappy we want to create a mobile
app that lets you pair it with your like
web browser so you can actually record
the audio with your own phone and of
course finally we do want speech to text
going as there's a lot of important data
that can be gathered from whatever the
transcription is for example by simple
like even by simple by simply filtering
out stop words and finding uncommon
words you can tell you what the teacher
was saying and say hey there are a few
keywords that were in your transcription
that were somehow missed in your
document alright so if you have any
questions about our hack or just
hackathons in general now is the time to
ask
or
glass
yeah we definitely thought about that
especially with document sharing and
even sharing recordings because
sometimes there's noise that happens
exactly yeah so that was something we
were considering we were still like
there might be privacy concerns like you
need to do it in a certain way so if you
know a student doesn't attend the class
like they can't get away with other
people's notes but I mean that's
something we've been thinking about for
sure
yeah
it's functional the thing is we set it
up after the hackathon very recently
hence the package problems on no NPM
didn't have a package lock file until
like late May and they and I don't know
if you guys worked with NPM but what
happens is that they do this terrible
thing but when you install a dependency
it assumes that dependencies will be
backwards compatible and also and also
when you install these dependencies they
aren't they install a bunch of other
dependencies which aren't added to your
package JSON and therefore aren't
versioned
which treats a lot of problems short
answer no it has it hasn't really
reached the stage where it's better than
like using Google Docs or something but
maybe at some point we'll see this
yes we can so our files aren't so it's a
firebase back-end so I don't know if you
guys know what firebase it's a Google
service that access the database but it
also has built in things for the
vacation which made it really easy for
us to use our storage for audio files is
actually just on a flash server um it
hits an end point and streams the audio
to the server and just saved that way
with IDs and certain timestamps and
obviously the file name is stored on the
firebase or the entire webview is built
with react it's no way an ideal set up
but it's something we were able to build
really quickly so it's not super
scalable but in terms of like we only
had 36 hours to build this so it was
pretty quick to make how many points add
in the actual contents of the document
we're also stored in firebase so
JavaScript and Python
yeah
um I think maybe so I mean like I said
earlier we were having issues with like
speech to text so at least when I'm
writing notes usually I'm a few lines
behind what the professor saying so it's
kind of hard to tie what the speech like
what's actually happening recorded by
the mic with what I'm typing right now
but with the data we do collect from the
notes I'm sure there's some insights
that can be gained and connections could
be made especially with the
crowdsourcing option or you could
actually connect points together and
build up a another document sorry we did
actually write a GD IDF which we're
never able to implement the idea
something like that or frequency inverse
basically the beacon we would compare a
different notes and we'd find out
certain words that stood out and
people's document so ones that were
unique beef between different samples
and actually based on that we could
theoretically it would be a sort of a
mildly moderately poor model but it
could actually determine which student
it would have the best notes
all right so I think that wraps it up
thanks for coming to a presentation shop
[Applause]